remember Jack nah our thoughts and
prayers are with the three families
these movements are consistent with
deliberate action by someone on the
plane
the operation has until and your face
the search was already a highly complex
multinational effort it has now become
even more difficult
the arrivals board at Beijing Airport
was the first indication that something
was wrong flight mh370 wasn't delayed it
was missing the news started to filter
out to the world and the relatives
waiting at the airport what had happened
overnight to the 239 people on board
their loved ones is a mystery my father
just died because of this news I had to
deal with that before I came here I
think the families will be satisfied
until they find out what happened to the
aircraft and I think you have a range of
emotions in there from people who are
very vocal and very angry about the
situation and very frustrated at the
lack of information in terms of where as
the aircraft the likelihood of this
having been something catastrophic
having happened to the airplane just
forget it it wasn't that catastrophic
things do not happen to modern airplanes
they just don't but new information
suggests the plane could have been
hijacked were now told that the plane
kept flying for hours after it
disappeared off radar screens but why
and in what direction this program will
examine the developments in this
fast-moving investigation this is mh370
a modern Boeing triple7 200 aircraft its
route was a scheduled red-eye flight
leaving kuala lumper daily at 35 minutes
past midnight flying through the night
to land in Beijing at six thirty in the
morning on saturday the 8th of March it
never arrived a multinational search
operation is launched rescue teams from
Malaysia Singapore and Vietnam start
looking for wreckage in the South China
Sea the Philippines sends a ship to join
that usual telltale from any airplane
that crashes into the sea the one thing
that immediately floats seat cushions
they're not tied down they they will as
their hull breaks up seat cushions will
be floating everywhere that's been a
trademark of aircraft crashing into the
sea the operation is initially centered
around the last known location of the
aircraft the route it should have taken
would have led it up the eastern coast
of Vietnam then north / China towards
Beijing around an hour into the flight
contact was lost near the tow to islands
at 1 30am air traffic control in kuala
lumper spoke to the flight deck we've
handed you over to Ho Chi Minh air
traffic control was the message ok
received good night was the reply it was
the last anyone heard of them early into
the search an oil slick is spotting it
quickly becomes the focus of attentions
but within hours is dismissed as having
no connection to the flight likewise
some debris floating on the sea that
looked like it could be a part of a
plane door it turned out not to be
commercial flights continue above the
Malay Peninsula
but the Chinese fearing terrorism might
be the cause tighten security at their
airports as it becomes apparent that
there is something not quite right about
the passenger manifest two names
shouldn't be on that one is an Austrian
could Christian kozel the other an
Italian could Luigi morality it turns
out that neither man boarded the plane
they are indeed alive and well
investigators discover that both had had
their passport stolen in Thailand
sir who then was travelling using their
names the sinister prospect of terrorism
becomes the latest line of inquiry if it
is terrorism and we don't know at all
that it is yet but if it is it's going
to be a real wake-up call to a region
that thought that was other people's
problem not theirs it takes almost two
days of checking intelligence databases
and going through CCTV systematically to
establish who the men are but finally
there is a breakthrough the two men
traveling on stolen passports are
identified as Iranians but with no known
connections to terrorism it is believed
they were trying to claim asylum in
Europe Interpol named them as pooey nor
mohammadi and 29 year old de lavar syed
mohammad reza they confirm that they
boarded the plane using the stolen
passports we know that once these two
individuals arrived in kuala lumpur on a
twentieth of februari they boarded
flight 370 using different identities
the operation by now is clutching at
straws kudos ermmm Dada for some
relatives waiting at a Beijing hotel for
news the desperation is overwhelmed
family lives have been put on hold until
the truth is known I've got a three year
old who's asking when's daddy gonna
skype know we'vewe've he's got a map on
his wall where daddy plotted where he's
dad's going to be and and so you know he
looks so he said when's dad gonna skype
and daddy be there when Willie skype so
luckily he's with friends at the moment
but I you know I will cross that bridge
when I so difficult is it to accept that
a plane can simply disappear with no
trace some choose not to
and Phillip is dead I refuse to believe
it of anybody that could survive
something like this at him I mean he's
such a fighter and he has so much to my
for the search in the vast Gulf of
Thailand and South China Sea is now
extended to an area covering hundreds of
square miles then a theory emerges that
the plane might have turned around
completely rescue teams begin looking at
the western Peninsula of Malaysia the
Straits of Malacca one of the world's
busiest shipping channels the reason for
the change is that the Malaysian
military say that they tracked a plane
there on radar at two-fifteen in the
early hours of Saturday morning around
45 minutes after the plane vanished from
air traffic control screens if the
airplane did turn off its original
course then it's flying over some very
sparsely populated areas including
places like the Burmese rainforest and
an airplane even as big as a triple
seven if it if it if it was intact when
it crashed into the rainforest it could
be it could be unseen for four months
they know there will be nothing to see
from above and to actually locate it on
the ground would be very difficult
indeed in another twist of possible hope
newly released satellite images appear
to show smoke rising from the ocean
south of Vietnam again search teams are
dispatched but like so many leads in
this investigation this one is quickly
dashed the Boeing triple7 200 is one of
the most modern passenger aircraft
currently in the skies to enormous
rolls-royce engines enable it to fly
huge distances even if one failed
should be able to keep flying without
any problem at all the rescue teams by
now have covered thousands of square
miles of open sea meticulously searching
for any sign of Malaysian Airlines
flight mh370 and the 239 people on board
but it transpires they were looking in
the wrong place all this time
then Phillip instead I refuse to believe
them this movements are consistent with
deliberate action by someone on the
plane on Saturday the eighth of March
Malaysian Airlines flight mh370 vanished
without trace and without reason its
whereabouts has confused experts and
baffled the world relatives wait for
answers many refusing to give up hope of
finding their loved ones alive the
search has now become a multinational
operation involving dozens of aircraft
and ships but still nobody knows what
happened to the 239 people on board this
fateful flight the longer the search
goes on theories that might have been
initially dismissed as outlandish are
now being treated as credible every day
the authorities brief the waiting
families on the latest in the
investigation but with no sign of the
plane the grief is becoming unbearable
emotions are running hard and then
finally some news a press conference is
called in Beijing the families prepared
to watch it nervously expect a week to
the day that flight mh370 went missing
with speculation running wild and
desperation growing the Malaysian Prime
Minister Najib Razak reveals to the
world major new developments we can say
with a high degree of certainty that the
aircraft communications addressing and
reporting system of acre
was disabled just before the aircraft
reach the east coast of Peninsular
Malaysia shortly afterwards near the
border between Malaysia and vietnamese
air traffic control the aircraft's
transponder was switched off it then
flew in a westerly direction back over
Peninsular Malaysia before turning
Northwest up until the point at which it
left military primary radar coverage
these movements are consistent with
deliberate action by someone on the
plane the search of the South China Sea
is now over but rescue teams face the
prospect of a new area which is much
bigger much harder according to the new
data
the last confirmed communication between
the plane and the satellite was at 8 11
km Malaysian time on Saturday it March
the investigation team is making further
calculations which will indicate how far
the aircraft may have flown after the
last point of contact this will help us
to refine the search the last verbal
contact the plane had with air traffic
control was near Viet Nam's totoo
islands on the original flight path
after it had been flying for an hour
it's now been confirmed that it then
turned west and was picked up on
military radar it's believed to her
flown within two flight corridors one
that stretches north over Thailand
towards the border with Kazakhstan and
Turkmenistan or through a southern one
that goes from Indonesia to the Indian
Ocean this is thought because a
satellite which is thirty-five thousand
eight hundred kilometers above sea level
in the Indian Ocean received a ping or a
signal from the plane from those
locations the aircraft had enough fuel
to carry on flying for another 2,700
miles the equivalent of five hours this
now is the search area the authorities
are looking at John Lindsay is a former
head of air safety at british airways
with vast experience flying the Boeing
triple7 the same model of aircraft that
has disappeared without trace and
professor David stubbles lectures at
City University in London he is a
specialist in radar and used to work
with the Royal Signals radar
establishment the last communication was
with Malaysian air traffic control and
they were handed over as the expression
goes to the vietnamese air traffic
control and never called in we know then
that there is there is ground tracking
ability of the aircraft but we also know
that the aircraft has a lot of
information and data that it also sends
back to the to the ground via its
various onboard communications device
yeah that's right so therefore what will
happen is the aircraft will be pinged
from the ground and its transponder on
board will actually be sending back its
position and its height let's just
remind ourselves that the airplane
intended flight path was over here
towards Beijing so and we know that it
had a fuel capability to get it to
Beijing and and Beyond because it will
be reserved fuel on there so typically
there will be enough fuel on board to
take it for an hours flying time passed
Beijing whoa so we have to consider then
an area that the airplane could be in
which would be a nice flying time beyond
Beijing so we're sweeping round really
all the way down to Sri Lanka the
Philippines and sort of East Timor over
here as being the the potential area but
there was some evidence coming out
earlier from the military radars again
which said that they got a track of an
aircraft which was unknown turning a
cross and in towards the elaman see so
so what that suggests is that it might
have at some stage turned in this
direction here if that was our airplane
then why was it there and why were there
not talking to anyone I doubt it was a
failure because of all the the duplicate
hasn't replicated systems on board so
therefore what we're left with is is to
say well there's an unknown reason why
it's come across here which means of
course not only do we have a search area
here but we have a search area here we
have a search area here here and all the
way around while suddenly around this
side assuming that that track was right
yeah radar only tracked it to a certain
distance but once beyond that it could
have turned in any direction
within the Bay of Bengal is entirely
unknown but the interesting thing is the
depth of the water here is about 60 to
70 meters the depth of the water out
here is several thousand meters it is
yes and so therefore if the aircraft did
come down in here it would have come
down in much I don't people water well
if we're looking at the extreme edge of
the of the range of action that the the
fuel could have provided I mean we have
to consider that the aircraft could even
have been a sort of it over there in
that in that sort of direction and in a
very long way away from the initial
search areas indeed which will be very
challenging I think for for the search
and rescue authorities the prospect
facing the search teams and the families
is now terrifying it is looking
increasingly likely that the plane was
hijacked it is also possible given
satellite data that the plane came down
in some of the deepest waters anywhere
on the planet in an area much bigger
than first thought not only that but if
it did follow a known aviation corridor
with the main detection systems turned
off that would suggest the hijacker or
hijackers knew exactly what they were
doing we are now looking at large tracts
of land for singing 11 countries as well
as deep and remote portions the number
of countries involved in the search and
rescue operation has increased from 14
to 25 which brings new challenges of
coordination and diplomacy to the search
effort now every passenger and crew
member is under suspicion once again
police in Malaysia searched the houses
of the two pilots and speak to their
families this flight simulator blowing
to captain zaharie is dismantled and
reassembled in the hunt for any clue
yesterday officers from the Royal
Malaysian police visited the home of the
pilot they spoke to family members of
the pilot and experts are examining the
pilots flight simulator
the police also visited the home of the
co-pilot according to Malaysian Airlines
the pilot and co-pilot did not ask to
fly together on MH 370 the Malaysian
Prime Minister has confirmed the a car
system was probably disabled but what
does that mean aircraft communications
addressing and reporting system or a
cars for short is a computer which sends
constant updates to the ground about the
health of a plane it will first try to
communicate over radio frequencies
before choosing to send signals back via
a satellite network called SATCOM pilots
can choose to request data and to send
it the system will also send automated
messages throughout the flight for these
systems to be active airlines have to
pay for companies to run them but the
systems are built into all aircraft so
just because you don't pay for the
service it doesn't mean it won't try to
transmit data it is very easy for
someone to pull the circuit breaker on
the planes transponder which sends
electronic replies to the ground when it
receives the radio signal it could also
do the same on the a car system but
despite all this the SATCOM antenna will
still automatically ping away trying to
find a satellite to log onto it is
possible for aircraft if you don't under
that as long as there's electrical power
to do a class system as long as there is
hope the search will go on that is the
promise of the Chinese premier no less
but even with all the resources that
superpower is dedicating to the cause
the fate of the malaysia airlines flight
remains unknown
the families wait longing for any small
sign the clue the marker anything in the
dark of a calm kuala lumper night mh370
took off on a routine flight north an
hour later it vanished in what must be
the greatest aviation mystery of recent
times